bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur votre
chaîne de vulgarisation politique
la chaîne qui vous explique les détails
de la vie politique française
aujourd'hui on va vous parler des étapes
du vote des lois ordinaires
pour commencer on va revenir sur ce qui
est l'ordinaire et sur la place de la
loi dans la hiérarchie des normes
françaises
de façon générale une loi c'est
finalement rien d'autre qu'un texte qui
est votée au parlement donc au sénat et
à l'assemblée nationale
c'est donc un texte qui relève du
pouvoir législatif
si on regarde la hiérarchie des normes
françaises
la loi est en dessous de la constitution
ça veut dire que toutes les lois doivent
respecter ce texte qui est notre texte
fondamental mais la loi est au dessus
des textes réglementaires qui sont les
décrets les arrêter et les circulaires
donc tous ces textes qui relève du
pouvoir exécutif et qui sont donc rédigé
par le président de la république le
gouvernement et l'administration doivent
respecter les lois concernant les
ordonnances c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué à vous expliquer donc je vous
invite à voir la vidéo qu'on a fait à ce
sujet pour mieux comprendre ce que c'est
des lois il y en a plusieurs types déjà
pour faire le lien entre la constitution
et des autres textes normatifs
on retrouve les lois organiques qui
précise et appliquent des articles de la
constitution
elles servent souvent à préciser
l'organisation et le fonctionnement des
pouvoirs publics et elles sont
obligatoirement soumises au contrôle du
conseil constitutionnel avant leur
promulgation
ensuite pour modifier la constitution
retrouve les lois constitutionnelles
elles sont votées à la suite d'une
procédure spéciale pour qu'elle soit
votée
il faut la corde 3 5e du parlement réuni
en congrès ou alors l'accord du peuple
par référendum
on retrouve aussi les loi référendaire
qu'elles sont votées par le peuple
directement et qui permettent le plus
souvent de répondre à une question
précise
pour finir on retrouve les lois
ordinaires qui sont les lois les plus
courantes et les plus nombreuses et ce
sont elles qui régissent la vie publique
les lois ordinaires elles sont définies
dans la constitution et elles
n'interviennent que dans les domaines
très importants comme les libertés
public le droit de réunion le droit
syndical la liberté religieuse
enfin globalement les grandes questions
qui concernent l'ensemble de la nation
mais pas les détails
pour tous les détails il y a les textes
réglementaires qui se recharge et nous
ici on va vous parler de la façon dont
votent les lois ordinaires pour
commencer la première étape c'est le
débat du texte on parle de projet de loi
si le texte vient du gouvernement et
dans ce cas le dépôt peut s'effectuer au
bureau de l'assemblée nationale ou du
sénat
ça n'a pas d'importance les propositions
moi c'est à dire les textes qui sont
rédigées par un ou plusieurs
parlementaires doivent être déposés au
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
si le timing d'un député ou au bureau du
sénat
sylvain armand sénateurs après le dépôt
il y à l'examen en première assemblée le
texte examiné par la commission
compétente
vous vous rappelez les commissions sont
les petits groupes de travail à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
cette commission va désigner un
rapporteur qui rédige un rapport sur le
texte et peut proposer des amendements
c'est à dire des modifications du texte
le rapport doit être adopté par la
commission avant d'être voté par la
première assemblée
quand le texte est mis à l'ordre du jour
les parlementaires votent pour chaque
article et amendement puis vote pour
l'ensemble du texte et transmettre leur
version du texte à la deuxième assemblée
la seconde assemblée examine le texte
après quatre semaines et peut aussi le
modifier le texte va alors repartir vers
la première assemblée et faire des
aller-retour jusqu'à ce que les deux
assemblées donc d'accord sur un texte
commun c'est la navette parlementaire
pendant laquelle seuls les articles
modifiés sont étudiées
le texte adopté lorsqu'il est votée dans
les mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
il faut savoir que la durée de l'examen
d'un texte pendant une séance est fixée
à l'avant ce pour permettre une bonne
organisation des débats
chaque groupe a un temps de parole
maximum et ce temps de parole est plus
important pour les groupes d'opposition
ce qui peut expliquer pourquoi parfois
on peut avoir l'impression de moins
entendre les groupes de la majorité
pendant le débat quand le temps de
parole est écoulé pour un groupe
les membres de ce groupe ne peuvent plus
prendre
à paroles ça évite que les groupes
d'opposition bloquent complètement le
débat en apportant une infinité
d'amendements bon mais même avec les
navettes parlementaires
ça peut arriver que les assemblées ne
tombent pas d'accord on que le
gouvernement ne soit pas d'accord avec
une des modifications apportées au texte
alors à ce moment là comment on fait et
bien il y a plusieurs cas ci c'est
l'assemblée nationale et sénat qui ne
sont pas d'accord on va utiliser la
procédure de commission mixte paritaire
elle est composée de sept députés et
sept sénateurs qui doivent essayer
d'aboutir à un texte commun
si elle n'y arrive pas le gouvernement
peut donner le dernier mot à l'assemblée
nationale si c'est l'assemblée nationale
et le gouvernement qui ne sont pas
d'accord le gouvernement a deux
possibilités
il peut par exemple demander un vote
unique et globale appelée vote bloqué
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de voter la loi
article par article est de voter chacun
maintenant l'assemblée est obligé de
voter en bloc le texte ou une partie de
celui-ci le gouvernement préfère et donc
de l'approuver ou de le rejeter ça veut
dire que l'assemblée ne peut donc pas
rajouter les amendements qu'elle
voudrait le gouvernement peut aussi
utiliser l'alinéa 3 de l'article 49 de
la constitution
le fameux 49 3 qui permet l'adoption
d'un texte sans débat
sauf mention censure de la part de
l'assemblée nationale si c'est le sénat
et le gouvernement qui ne sont pas
d'accord
le gouvernement peut utiliser le vote
bloqué ou donner le dernier mot à
l'assemblée nationale concernant les
lois organiques
l'accord du sénat est obligatoire donc
le gouvernement ne peut pas donner le
dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale une
fois que le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale se sont mis d'accord sur un
texte
il est promulguée c'est à dire rendu
applicable par un décret du président de
la république
pendant ce temps le conseil
constitutionnel peut être saisi pour
vérifier que la loi est bien conforme à
la constitution et président peut
demander un nouvel examen du texte par
les assemblées
la loi va entrer en vigueur après sa
publication au journal officiel de la
république française
certaines lois n'ont pas besoin de
mesures d'application elles peuvent être
directement mises en place mais d'autres
existent des décrets arrêtés ou
circulaires qui sont parfois prévu dans
le corps de la halle
c'est premier ministre avec les membres
du gouvernement qui vérifie la bonne
exécution de la loi
une fois la loi mise en place le
parlement et le gouvernement doivent
l'évaluer et si besoin la modifier pour
l'adapter le mieux possible aux
nécessités du terme
enfin comme on l'a dit au début de cette
vidéo toutes les lois doivent respecter
la constitution
pour vérifier cette conformité il est un
organisme que vous connaissez peut-être
parce qu'on en a parlé dans une
précédente vidéo c'est le conseil
constitutionnel et voilà j'espère que
cet épisode vous aura plu et que vous
comprenez maintenant comment les lois
ordinaires sont votés
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à mettre 1 pouces bleus et à la
partager n'hésitez pas aussi à nous
mettre dans les commentaires si il ya
des sujets que vous voudriez que l'on
traite pour une prochaine vidéo
merci à tous et à bientôt